today I'm going to talk about the
hypocrisy of Republicans when it comes
to business Freedom that they claim to
espouse and low regulations which they
claim to support and this is all kind of
coming on the heels of yesterday's Ron
DeSantis Disney World I'll build a
prison next to Disney threat and
controversy which is really just one of
dozens and dozens of data points of
Republicans who claim to be about
business freedom and low regulation
immediately abandoning that principle to
the extent that it's even a principle as
soon as it's politically inconvenient
now in order to understand where this
hypocrisy comes from and why it's so
glaring today you really have to
understand the history of the Republican
party as for decades and decades and
decades claiming to be the party of
business freedom of low regulations of
economic freedom and uh pro-business and
all of these things they said for
decades excessive regulation is a burden
on businesses and it hurts profits and
it stifles economic growth and therefore
it prevents hiring and the best thing we
can do for workers and for the economy
and for investors for everybody
is to keep regulations low and stay out
of the way of businesses let the market
decide which businesses succeed and
which businesses fail the truth is so
much more pathetic it's we support
business freedom in theory when it suits
our interests and doesn't conflict with
personal vendettas grievances or other
inconvenient realities now let's take a
look at some examples and again
understand that there was a period even
if you disagree with this uh obsessive
focus on unburdening businesses or
regulations you might disagree with that
we can still acknowledge that at a
certain point
conservatives as they once were
were actually much more committed to
that I would still disagree with them in
many cases and say no we need regulation
but there was a point at which when they
said it they meant it that's not the
case anymore Twitter Twitter is a recent
example that's a glaring one when it
comes to Twitter
many of these right-wingers immediately
abandoned their stated principles of
getting rid of burdensome regulations
and separating government from what
private companies do and said no Twitter
should be forced to publish my coveted
disinformation Twitter should be forced
to publish Hunter Biden nude pics which
violate their own terms of service
Twitter should be forced to let
governments decide or the government
decide what hateful ideology ideology or
hateful speech should be published
rather than saying let Twitter figure
out what it wants to do let Twitter
figure out what's good or bad for
business let Twitter make its decisions
assuming they're not illegal and let the
market of ideas and the marketplace of
people decide oh I don't like what
Twitter is doing so I'm not going to be
on Twitter anymore
that's the way that they claim they
operate but as Twitter showed us that's
not actually the way they operate when
they want to force their disinformation
onto a private platform Twitter
Republicans at one point pushed a law
that would have prevented States from
enacting their own regulations on
certain products they would argue oh you
know we need to protect businesses from
a patchwork of different regulations
from state to state it's burdensome to
business to say well we're going to
regulate your product this way in
Delaware but in New York it's going to
be different and then in Florida it's
going to be different so they pushed a
law that said you can't do that you
can't just let states regulate products
differently in each state but when it
comes to environmental regulations
Republicans don't care about a patchwork
of regulations they want to strip the
epa's federal power for example to
regulate greenhouse gas emissions at the
federal level and listen there are
states that aren't worried about that we
know let if a state isn't concerned if
you have a state like Montana for
example Jared Diamond has written about
this a lot if Montana wants to let the
uh you know the soil them the land and
every water be ravaged by pollution or
Wyoming or let them do it you can't have
this oppressive EPA come in and tell
every state what they have to do well
that's the principle that you are now
going against you're against the
patchwork of laws but now you're okay
with the patchwork of laws if it might
prevent the regulation of greenhouse
gases they're willing to do it 50
different ways in each of the 50 states
because they want to make it difficult
to regulate greenhouse gas emissions
then we've got subsidies and this is you
know each one of these things I'm
mentioning is a category unto itself
with many examples we could go into but
let's now talk about subsidies the right
claims to be against government
intervention in the economy
picking winners and losers
Etc but they have no problem handing out
billions of dollars in subsidies to
certain industries including oil and
others when they are politically
convenient businesses when it comes to
labor regulations Republicans suddenly
are big fans of government intervention
they love the idea of how can we
interfere with business
to prevent workers from organizing and
forming unions for example they support
laws that make it more difficult for
workers to sue employers when there are
workplace violations you know if you
don't want to regulate the businesses
because you claim oh they have a they
have an incentive to regulate themselves
and if they put out a dangerous product
they'll get sued and they'll lose market
share and if they don't have good
working conditions for their employees
their employees will sue or quit well
but then they also want to make it more
difficult for the employees to sue
because it's in their interests the
truth as many of you have long suspected
is that Republicans only care about
business freedom and unburdening from
burdensome regulations when it serves
their interests when it comes to
protecting the environment or protecting
workers suddenly regulations are a
burden that need to be left did this uh
or or you need to put in a regulation
you need to put in a regulation that
prevents others from putting in
regulations it's whatever is convenient
at the time and this at the end of the
day is bad for the economy
it's bad for the sort of average health
of people as they are affected by the
lack of Regulation or a very oppressive
type of Regulation depending on who it
is that benefits and who is hurt the
well-being of workers the environment I
mean you all know it so we're going to
be going through over the next several
weeks each of these stated principles
unburden ourselves from regulation
except when you want to force your will
onto corporations we're going to look at
each of these and there are so many of
these stated principles that they claim
but don't actually follow this is the
first one business Freedom low
regulation we'll get to others over the
next few weeks